hey guys today we have this 2013 Misan
Altima we're going to be adding a new
smart key fob using the km1 100 outo km
100 so we have one working key fob and
we're going to give them this Universal
key all right let's get
[Music]
started
all right first thing we're going to
verify if everything
works so I know this one is new there's
no battery
still you can see it's not making any
noise this one you can lock do that
unlock trunk still
works and make sure everything works far
and
beep alarm works and the remote start
work make sure that one
working um lock it then hold the remote
start start the car all right so
everything works perfectly with this one
so let's go
ahead lock this
one
and let's turn it off so let's go ahead
um go to the km 100 Alro km 100 and
let's go
ahead we need to generate one of this
smart key Universal
key all right first we're going to go
ahead open this up and put a battery all
right to open this just press this one
on the
bottom okay this one will slide
out then I think this one
here to pop
open so just going to pry that
out all the BNS are facing down so it
won't fall apart and it will try to fall
apart on
you but make sure you put it
back
properly so you have this here
and this one I think is 2032 so I'm
going to use a
battery I'm going to open
this
okay then said positive in this side so
the positive which is the flat
one goes
here go and before we close it make sure
that all the buttons
are in proper
position so we're going to go ahead and
close it
slowly
see you go let's put it close
it everything is still intact buttons
cuz sometimes it doesn't get a line
while putting it back
you
see like this one it won't go straight
because the spring is not centered so
I'm just going to push the
spring just a little
bit so it's
Center then there you
go that's it that's it so that's close
so now we have battery so you can see
this is not programmed cuz it
doesn't lock unlock the car so go ahead
close this
one then we're going to generate this
for a
proper FCC on this one so let's go ahead
put right here Universal
key and
then going to
make the
[Music]
[Applause]
Nissan right
here and then the model the
[Music]
Ultima then year it's
2013 so that's the FCC that we have let
me pull it up hold the FCC make sure
it's right I have a reference
here this one is Ultima
four-door and that's the
KR 5 S18
44104 so looks like pretty similar and
we're going to look for a five Bon 1 2 3
5 so I'm going to go down find a five
Buton ones I think 1 2 3 4 five I think
this is the very bottom one is five
button so I'm going to click that
one and then I'm going go
ahead put the
remote the universal key on top of it
and then I'm going to go
ahead generate Universal
key so make sure you have the battery
first before you do the generating the
remote and this might take a little
while so make sure you don't move it you
don't have to be really inside the slot
as long as you're on top of it and that
one is
generating 70%
20% all
[Music]
right
look that
okay okay now we're in 100% so you can
see Universal key generation is
completed do you want to continue the
generation that means if you want to
make another one so I'm going to
say
completed continue go
completed if you continue you get
another one you make another one so now
you can go to
emo I'm going to get my
my OB to connect
it to the car now we're in the car I'm
going to go ahead connect this to the
car I
think not sure where is it at I
think somewhere here there you go right
in the
middle upside
down there you
go
there you go I'm
connected there you
go I'm going go ahead put my hazard
light
on then I'm going to have the key with
me grab the the original
key right
here so I got the hazard
on good
spot and
then because we have a key I'm going go
ahead turn on the car press one press
two press it
twice let me go ahead go to
emo all right we're on emo right now
turn on the hazard warning light we have
it turn on open and close the driver
door once so we're going to head open
and it says open and close it
so open and close the driver door
once turn the ignition turn on the
ignition and press okay we got the
ignition on already so press
okay so
communicating all right s um scanning
vehicle system
so just have to be patient on this one
so we have both the keys here the um
working key and the one we just
generated
so let's go to emo stus
scan and then scanning the whole car
make sure there's no problem if there is
we're going to
erase the whole thing got a quick DTC
eraser couple
codes we we discode if you want
to I'm going go ahead quick DTC eraser
so we don't have any
problem um programming the
keys
okay think everything is okay let's go
add key
guided there you
go you go ahead start get pin the pin
Press
Start execution of this function will
erase all garden key yes it will so you
got to be careful this is going to be
erased but it's fine let's go yes turn
off the
ignition press one so that's
off as are still on open and close the
driver door open close it press
okay place the back of the smart key
against the
ignition the original key place it at
the back the smart key against ignition
so we're going to put it
there
right there and press
okay so we have it there that's it h the
beat trying to get the pin operation
operate according the following press
the push P ignition switch for 2 seconds
for more and turn on the ignition to on
position so we're going to wall here
we're going to press the
button hold it until the ignition is on
so
hold
it then it turns
on stay there so we press
okay or the ignition of dashboard normal
condition after they turn on they're
normal so we press
yes
okay I'm still holding it there
turn off the ignition and wait for 3
second so turn it off press
one till I turn off press one two 3 and
press
okay press the push start button once
attach the smart key that need to be
programmed to push start button whether
the instrument light up and press
yes okay so let's go ahead with this one
to is this is deleted
okay
okay let's put this
one turn
on all right let press okay
Yes program success continue to program
the next one yes turn off the ignition
and wait for 3 seconds
so turn it off then wait for 3 seconds
remember everything was deleted so you
have to program the first one first then
you're going to prr the next one so 3 2
1 press okay press the start button once
again with the next one that we have so
we have this
one put it at the
back of the push start then hold it
press it until it turn
on everything turns
on okay and press
Yes program success continue to the next
one no cuz that's the last one we have
turn off the ignition wait for 3
second turn it
off once it's
goodbye wait for 3 second 3 2
1 okay keep programming succeeded
perform the
following and open and close open and
close the door once click the unlock key
start Eng for 5 seconds we see open and
close it and we're going to check if
everything is
okay let's see this should lock it
unlock
it so it's not quite
done so we're going to go
ahead
turn off the
car CU this is the thing with these we
got to make sure everything is
done so that we're going to turn on and
off this one with this one with the
original key so I'm going to go ahead
turn it
on make sure you got to have a
um make sure push that couple
times until it says program
succeeded
keep doing that couple
times there you go key registration
complete you see
that you got to have
that that message even though your
programmer said is done so I just keep
keep pressing the button with your the
first one that you made that you created
so that is
done open and close it let's see see
that it
locks and unlock it and we're going to
check theing this one with the second
let's
see
lock unlock see that lock unlock all
right so we got that program so you can
see this will will
lock unlock
lock
and lo and close that one again and
panic button that works same thing with
this new one that we made lock unlock
let see lock
unlock there you go open the trunk and
the
panic and the most important one is if
you going to start the car let's go
ahead open
it I'm going to leave both of them
outside and then as you can see try to
start the
car key ID incorrect because there's no
key so we're going to grab one of the
original
one leave it
inside start the car it's no
problem all right and then let's remove
that from the outside
with the brand new one that we
have there you go start the
car and it works perfectly all right
guys hope you like that video so we
added a key smart key using the outo km
100 you know it's not perfect but it
does the job very handy and so this is
for the 2013 Nissan
Ultima all right I hope you like the
video to key
fob
and don't forget to like And subscribe
share the video hope you enjoy
it all right
guys next video